[Music]
what is up everybody it's Santa Mak here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about some pretty
far-fetched theories that I've been
seeing everywhere including reddit a
whole bunch of YouTube videos and all
over my youtube comments these theories
include that Goku will become the next
grand priest or that the grand priest
will become Goku's new master or that
Goku will somehow become an angel I want
to make it clear right away that I am
NOT saying that these theories are true
I'm going to examine them and give you
my opinion on whether they make sense
before we get started I want to give a
quick shout out to the Dragon Ball amino
app they reached out to us because they
appreciate the fan community that we
have here in anime uproar and they have
supported this channel in the past so we
really appreciate that I have been
personally using Amino for a long time
and amino communities are a great place
to interact with thousands of fellow
fans as you can see the Dragon Ball
amino features some extremely cool fan
art public chats and other ways to
interact and there are often hundreds of
fans online at the same time we have our
own profile so you can check us out and
share your fan art with us if you'd like
to see it featured in a future video the
app is totally free and beyond
Dragonball there are other communities
to discover like attack on Titan seven
deadly sins my hero academia and more
now about those theories and again don't
forget I'm making this video because it
was highly requested in the comments and
because I thought it would be fun not
because I believe every Theory I see as
far as I can tell there are two major
factors that have inspired these various
theories the first is ultra instinct and
especially now that we found out that
Goku's mastered ultra instinct we'll
make his hair turn silver or white we
know that the Angels and the grand
priests all have white hair and we know
that they have all mastered ultra
instinct so the idea here is that Goku's
knew silver or white hair is a sign that
he has risen to the level of an angel
and that he is becoming unintel the
second major factor is the ending of
Dragon Ball Z if you think back to the
peaceful world saga in the last three
episodes of Dragon Ball Z in particular
you will remember that after a time skip
that takes us beyond the events of
Dragon Ball super chronologically we see
Goku wearing a completely different gear
or training uniform he is wearing a
light blue key with a white belt blueish
steel pants and orange wristbands many
people see this as significant because
Goku ze changes throughout the Dragon
Ball franchise to reflect the different
masters that he is training under so
just as an example when he trains under
Master Roshi Goku receives a key with
the kanji or symbol for turtle because
of course Master Roshi is the turtle
hermit when training under King Kai King
Kai's kanji is added to the back of Goku
ski and of course when training with
wheeze both Goku and Vegeta have Lisa's
own symbol added to the front of their
training uniform so the argument is that
Goku's new blue key along with the
orange wristbands is a sign that either
he has become the next grand priest and
so he has adopted the color scheme that
the grand priest wears and of course we
know that the grand priest wears blue
with an orange symbol on the front that
looks like an upside-down pyramid or
triangle and the other interpretation is
that maybe this new color scheme changes
because Goku has started training under
the grand priest and so in order to
honor his new master Goku decided to
wear a new uniform
okay so let's examine this idea that
Goku will become the next grand priest
first this idea stems from the fact that
Goku is allegedly good friends with Zeno
and for this reason Zeno will pick Goku
to become his new right-hand man and the
new grand priest
however I personally do not see any
reason why the grand priest would want
to step down from his role the grand
priest is not mortal so it's not like he
needs to worry about getting too old and
going into retirement and from
everything we've seen he seems to be
getting along quite well with Zeno I
believe that this theory about Goku
replacing the grand priest comes from
the idea that the grand priest is evil
and that Goku will have to defeat him
and then replace him as xennos attendant
but as you guys know I personally don't
think that the grand priest is evil or a
villain so I believe that this theory is
out of the question
I mean maybe the grand priest
tired of serving under Zeno because the
Omni king is so naive and childish so
maybe he would want to try to get Goku
to replace him since Goku is often very
immature and childish himself so I guess
maybe he would make a better companion
for Zeno but we have to remember that
Goku is not immortal and the Omni King
is so even if Goku took over as the next
grand priest he could only serve Zeno
for a very short period of time from
xennos perspective regarding this theory
that goku might somehow become the next
grand priest I just don't see it
happening however the idea that the
grand priest might decide to train Goku
is much more plausible Goku is obviously
very interested in training under the
strongest fighter he can find and we
know that the grand priest is stronger
than wheeze the grand priest does show
an interest in Goku earlier on in the
series when he first meets him and
because of this we see invites the grand
priest to come and visit universe 7 so
this could be foreshadowing that the
grand priest will take Goku on and
become his new master and then after the
grand priest trains Goku Goku will go on
to train uber which is what he ends up
doing at the end of Dragon Ball Z and
just in case you don't remember boob is
a ten year old boy who is the
reincarnation of majin buu aka Kid Buu
but in the body of a good person
personally I could definitely see this
one happening especially now that the
Tournament of Power is ending I can
totally see the grand priests being
impressed with Goku's performance at the
tournament and I can also see Goku
begging the grand priest to train him so
maybe as a reward for his strong showing
at the tournament the grand priest will
give in and become Goku's new master
this theory is definitely possible in my
opinion and finally the theory that Goku
will himself become an angel now I get
why some people feel this way Goku's
hair is becoming similar to the hair of
the angels he is mastering ultra
instinct like the angels and of course
we know that the angels are more
powerful than the gods of destruction so
as Goku surpasses the level of a god of
destruction his logical next step is to
strive to reach the power of angels some
also believe that maybe the reason Goku
decides to train foob at the end of Jang
of allsey is because Goku has become the
new angel for universe
and he is training food just like we
strained him and Vegeta with the goal
being to make food into one of the
protectors of universe 7 however it
seems pretty clear that the angels are
all members of a specific race and that
they have similar physical features
which doesn't just include white hair
but also blue skin and so on some people
have suggested that maybe the reason
that all the angels have white hair is
because they are in a permanent state of
mastered ultra instinct but I don't
think that that makes sense
we know that's a mas who had naturally
white hair even though he wasn't an
angel so again the fact that your hair
becomes white does not automatically
make you an angel I can see the argument
that Goku after mastering ultra instinct
has surpassed the power of a god of
destruction and is approaching the power
of an angel but being as strong as an
angel does not actually make him one and
so in terms of the angel theory it's
definitely a no from me and that is my
opinion on these three currently popular
theories I think that the grand priests
deciding to train Goku after the
tournament is plausible and I could see
it happening but I do not think that
Goku will become either an angel or the
next Grand Prix's feel free to let me
know what you guys think about these
theories and feel free to share any
theories of your own down in the
comments if you enjoy the Dragon Ball
super content on this channel and you
want to see more be sure to leave a like
to let me know if you are new don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell we are now posting
daily anime content on Twitter and
Instagram so feel free to follow us at
anime uproar and if you want to discuss
anime theories recommendations and more
on a daily basis feel free to join our
discord server link in the description
as always thank you all so much for
watching and until next time see us
space cowboys
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]